so here we are at the fence you might be
wondering why we have a fence in the
middle of our campus it doesn't really
seem to serve any kind of real purpose
and there's a story behind it when our
school was founded this location called
the cut was actually a very large and
deep ravine so there was a bridge on
this location and the students would
hang out on the bridge they'd make dates
there it was kind of a great spot on
campus for socializing but when
construction started happening in the
university in the early 1900's displaced
a lot of dirt so they used that dirt to
fill in the ravine and they didn't need
a bridge any longer the students were
really disappointed to lose their
favorite meeting spot so the graduating
class of 1923 erected a fence in the
bridges honor and that was a spot for
students to hang out but the
administration was very disappointed
with this they didn't want the students
watering in the middle of campus and
they thought the fence was an eyesore so
they decided to tear it down
however the night before it was to be
torn down the legend of the fence
tells us that a group of fraternity
brothers painted an advertisement on the
fence for a party they were going to be
having and because everyone sees the
fence at least once every day it serves
as an excellent message board everyone
knew about the fence and the legend says
it was the most successful party in our
school's history the administration
relented they let us keep the fence to
use as a message board and we've been
using it for that express purpose ever
since
we paint all kinds of messages on the
fence and it's actually so popular we
have a number of rules surrounding its
use the first of which is you have to
paint it between the hours of midnight
and 6:00 a.m. with no exceptions second
roll is you've got to have two members
of your organization whatever group you
might be with claiming the fence on the
gravel area around the fence at all
times for as long as you want your
message to stay on the fence so if that
means you want your message there for a
week you're staying there for a week we
have electrical outlets around the fence
in the clock tower so that students can
plug in space heaters or stereos or
laptops anything they need to make the
fence a livable area a lot of students
will erect tents more recently they've
been starting to build shacks out of
plywood it's a lot of fun here out of
the fence the other rule is that you
have to use hand-held paintbrushes and
you have to paint the fence in its
entirety
if campus police catches you painting
the fence with spray paint or rollers
they will give you a ticket for
vandalism
this is actually not the original fence
that I'm sitting on the original was in
the Guinness Book of World Records it
was the most painted upon object in the
world but in 1993 it did collapse under
its own weight it's about 70 years old
that brought it out and fell over so we
replaced it with a steel reinforced
concrete fence it's not going anywhere
anytime soon
the original fence had about six inches
of paint on it they've taken core
samples of this version and we have
about four inches of paint so we are
working hard on beating the old record